hi folks welcome back you can see I'm
standing here in the doorway Martha's
place next to Jamie and Lauren they're
getting ready to do their debt free
scream this is always so exciting our
favorite part of the show when people
reach the finish line this is the finish
line on an unbelievable journey that's
always very exciting it's always fun
when they bring their families and this
is these are there kiddos right here
what's your name and I know her name
will you tell what's your name yeah
Danielle Danielle is 4 is she not the
cutest thing you've ever seen in all
your life are you guys ready to scream
you're gonna scream really loud your
brother just put rabbit ears on you so
I'm gonna do it look at that hey mom and
dad are up right now in the lobby of
Ramsey solutions Jamie and Lauren are
with us hey guys how are you hey Dave
hey welcome welcome where you guys from
we're from Austin Texas
well Round Rock just outside Austin very
fun and here in Nashville all the way
here to do your debt-free scream oh wow
how much have you paid off a hundred and
five thousand total over seven a half
years we kind of had two sections we
started with 28,000 in consumer debt and
then we paid off our mortgage just last
month very cool what's the house worth
about 150 thousand how old are you - 31
anyway you have paid for house
that's crazy you're stinking weird like
it I mean that's weird that's awesome
man very cool making what kind of income
during this seven and a half years well
we started out as broke newlyweds with
nothing but each other making about
twenty eight thousand and gradually
finish school got raises got 78,000 last
year one hundred and fifteen thousand
plus some extra I got us around 130 with
etics of extra jobs I love it what do
you guys do for a living I'm a software
engineer I mix home yeah and I teach the
kids so oh very cool excellent and you
can have how many kids three three kids
31 years old and I paid $450,000 house
making
fifteen a year you're killing it thank
you this is awesome
very cool so what puts you on a track
like this I mean so like you just
started when you got married seven a
half years ago on the track would you
have got great parents or what well
we've actually been married about ten
years no years okay so as well so you
weren't smart the whole time okay no no
our church was doing an FPU and I was
kind of skeptical of the whole thing but
our small group got into it and we went
to the class and showed up and took
notes and did it and we said oh that's a
pretty good idea and then near the end
of the class some of our friends
actually announced that they'd paid off
their house like we'd never seen anyone
actually pay off their house Wow no debt
it's weird
we want that yeah want that kind of
weird yeah so Lauren Jamie strikes me as
the kind of guy who he doesn't do
something easily but once he decides to
do it there's like no stopping him I I
think we're pretty much the same with
that that we found a good plan and we're
like yeah I think we can do this let's
let's do it and it was a lot of fun to
work together yeah very cool so when
people here I mean you look like fairly
normal people but you're wearing I mean
when they hear that you know sweet
little couple three three kids 31 years
old and you have a pay-for house they
have their jaw drops and they say how
did you do that what do you tell them we
tell them a secret to getting out of
debt is well definitely the budget and
you know sing down every month making
you know writing down all what your
money's gonna do and sticking to that
and being on the same page working
together won't work if you're both doing
different things and really contentment
and being okay with not having every
single thing that everyone else has and
just being happy with what God's given
you already seven half years is a long
journey how did you stick with
well we did the first paying off our
consumer debt in our college debt and we
found that it just really worked right
after we finished our emergency fund
baby step number three Jamie got laid
off Oh like the next month Wow
and we're like whoa that emergency fund
that saved us he wasn't working for six
months Wow and you know the same thing
happened when right after we pay off the
house like a week ago
his car broke and needs a new car and
we're like whoa
now we've we've got money for all those
things and it just works very cool very
practical huh that's fun what was the
toughest part about this for each of you
I guess we had this car that Lauren had
it before we were married and we drove
it up until that last year I got it it
would has in three medium two major
accidents on three different sides and
I'd kind of duct tape and benches
together this thing is a lie about Steve
what kind of car is this
that's a 97 Buick LeSabre oh my god and
it's been hit on every side there was
one good side and you're driving that
thing Lord you don't seem like you care
but well it actually it was fun after a
while like it got hitting so bad that
the trunk wouldn't stay closed so Jamie
Jimmy bolted a padlock on to the trunk
to keep it closed and after what was
kind of fun you know people are riding
your bumper you're like yeah go ahead
give me a new car
you just don't carry brake lights might
not work to you you know someone dings
your car you're like yeah whatever
damn with the other ones well you have
truly I see the padlock in the picture
that's hilarious
you have truly lived like no one else
and and driven like no one else so now
you can drive like no one else because
you guys have no payments does that sunk
in it's getting there how's it feel it's
pretty awesome we
we're just on our way back from kind of
our little victory tour we took the kids
to Disney World and Universal Studios
it's kind of let them to see that you
know you live like no one else
this is living like no one else there
you go ah mic drop that's good yeah and
and so we saved up for that and so I
think next next budgets gonna be the one
where you know we're not saving up for
some big crazy thing or paying off
anything it's just gonna be like live
like normal people but with a lot more
room in the budget yeah like lots like
no payments at all yeah no house payment
no car payment no student loan that's
been around so long you think it's a bet
I mean everything straightened out here
very very very cool well congratulations
you two very well done so uh the
children's names are what as Philip
Stephen and Danielle Phillip Stephen and
Danielle now have they been practicing
their debt free screen actually all
right cool and and you brought you've
also brought some other support crew who
else was here no no no not you okay I'm
sorry I'm sorry there's a bunch of folks
out there I thought someone with you
okay
very cool all right friends after Jamie
and Lauren Phillip Stephen and Danielle
Austin Texas a hundred and five thousand
dollars paid off they paid off their
house and everything at 31 years old you
guys Rock count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one
great job you guys absolutely awesome
man that's how you do it that is how you
do it right there
absolutely fabulous I love it I love it
I love it
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind